What does it mean when I have high
vitamin B12 on my blood test?
This is a common question
when I'm going over somebody's blood work
because it's a common
physiological fine-dead on blood work elevated B12
Okay, so most people think and many people have been told
To stop taking their B12 if they have elevated B12
I can't tell you how many times I've heard that my doctor told me to stop taking B12 because my blood
Serum B12 was elevated or they just thought why better stop taking the B12 than I'm taking because my B12 was elevated on my blood
That's not correct
Thinking so let me explain why
So B12 that you're going to take as a supplement or that you're going to consume as a food has to be absorbed
And it's absorbed through a process of
Your stomach cells the varietal cells that your stomach
Create and release this what we called intrinsic factor
And B12 needs a intrinsic factor to be absorbed in the gut. So that attaches to the B12 that you absorb the B12
So if you have elevated serum B12 levels that means you have adequate absorption of B12
Many times it's because you're taking way too way more than a person needs
But then you have elevated serum B12 levels
Is that a bad thing?
No, that's not a bad thing. Is there any harm in having elevated serum B12 levels?
No, there's no harm in that but can that be an indication of something? It can
So if a person is taking exogenous B12 supplementation and they have elevated B12
Then
They're that's a good sign because they're making a intrinsic factor. So they're absorbing most of what they're taking
in that capsule
Or so they're getting it into their system
But it can be a side if there's elevated serum B12 also of a what's called a functional B12 deficiency
Because it's not getting into the tissues
So elevated serum B12 and be a side of
B12 deficiency in that it's not getting it's a functional deficiency because it's not getting into the tissues
So in that case, so whatever I see a blood test with somebody with elevated B12
And they say should I stop taking B12 or my doctor told me to stop taking B12
I said no keep taking B12 because we need that higher level of B12
circulating in your bloodstream to keep you know and
fairly adequate amount of
B12 in the tissues
So there's no harm in having
Don't even serum B12
But it's usually a side of the person not having
enough
But you know not getting into the tissues as well. So they actually need to keep that serum B12 at an elevated level
Now if a person that would absolutely be the case if the person is saying I don't have any supplements that I'm taking B12 as
It you know not taking a sublingual B12 because usually the B12s like we sell hydroxyl
Prohydroxyl
Chobolamine which is a
Form of B12. There's multiple different forms of B12
Chobolamine is the B12 and it has to be bound to something. So if you get it as a supplement
It will be either
Cyanol Chobolamine which I don't think that's a good form to take
It's more a synthetic form. So I don't think anybody should take that
Most supplements will be a methyl Chobolamine and I don't think that's a good form to take for a cancer patient because you don't want excess methyl groups
If you have a diagnosis of cancer because excess methyl groups
Will basically silence have the ability to silence to their suppressor gene so you can actually be
Blocking
The intrinsic apoptotic pathway so you shouldn't be taking methyl B12 as a cancer patient
But most B12 supplementation out there is methyl B12
So I would recommend if the person is deficient in B12 you should be taking a hydroxyl
Chobolamine or an adenosyl Chobolamine
And you should be taking it as a Lawsage so that you're absorbing it sublingually
Through your mucus membranes in your mouth
And because so many people haven't
If they have a deficiency in B12
It's because they have a deficiency in the
production of the transit factor by the bridal cells of the stomach and that's usually because
They have hypochloridria so the creation of a transit factor by the bridal cells of the stomach is completely dependent upon
The pH of the stomach so if you have a
You have an increased pH of the stomach. We did a decrease hydrochloric acid, which is hypochloridria
You're going to have a decreased production of a transit factor and you're setting yourself up for a B12 deficiency, which is
Which is a type of anemia so you end up with a B12 anemia
so
And that's all circulate back to hypochloridria being a major cause at B12 anemia
But the question was about high B12 so high B12 is typically found that somebody who's taking B12 supplementation
And then there it could be a functional
Issue because they're not getting as much B12 into the tissues, which would be a reason why you should keep taking B12 because there's no harm in keeping the high syrup level of B12
You can have other issues with B12 heavy to elevated B12 with other conditions like chronic
um
Milo
Prolific disorders
A person could have diabetes that can show elevated B12 heart failure can show an elevated B12
obesity aids and other
others
You know serious liver conditions can show a elevated B12 so again
One blood test gives you clues to look at other things
So you don't just look at oh, I just have elevated B12
Well, where is my other where are my other markers in relation to functional slash optimal ranges not just lab ranges
So again, you look at a blood test in correlation with other signs and symptoms and other objectives and subjective data in order to arrive at a clinical diagnosis